hey guys we're here with the official
flash character breakdown from
NetherRealm now this did come from a
developer livestream so if you see
something weird remember that it's a
work in progress and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for all the latest injustice
two character reveals and breakdowns Oh
[Music]
No okay that's one oh no that's two I
was just ran out the else it
doesn't--it's counts that counts that's
two okay fine great that's not even the
right moon before
[Music]
alright so was your fifth time uh I'm
doing a first try every time anyone yeah
yeah it cetera the time would it matter
true true so so flashes back and just
like the original injustice he is the
master of blows rush down bad space
mix-ups he has a couple of new moves
guess it's new combo which is a great
combo enter
pressure tool because it's advantage on
block and what's really cool my /e yeah
hahaha
yeah good row which is personally my
favorite throw the game class yeah
friends pretty awesome and then the
bigger change is he has three brand new
special moves mm-hmm he has lightning
punches which isn't very fast advancing
high attacks in shows including full
take punches and you can beat her Burnet
and it's combo sorry
so that has to hit it has to hit right
unblock just the one comes out but on
hit commuter burners and this is very
fast food that covers distance very very
quickly it is a high so they can duck it
and publish it but it's so fast that's
gonna be kind of yeah yeah you got to be
right the second one we just kind of
teased you and this is a mr. Fleury
where he actually slows down time and
there's a flurry and cutlery while he
waits and this is an excellent
conference chunk of damage and it's a
good outcome when they're even Tyler
yeah yeah that simple inputs is what we
mean to say yeah we wait and then I will
say um I in my person that's my favorite
innovation it's great I just love that
image so in great audio yeah right on
yeah that's one of my favorite now can
you meet her burn that well we're gonna
get to that okay and then he has 2000
fists where he creates this tornado way
and this is the combo start
it's an anti-air move
you know you can use it at the end of a
string and then if you meter burnin and
get up income so if you think we're
going to jump
you can do it frantically and it has a
very big hitbox no catch them pretty
much halfway in the air and you get to
combo I want to say uh just real quick I
say tweet last week about a meter burn
somebody like who may be new to our game
I know a lot of you aren't but just you
explain it well meter burn is basically
an enhanced version of a special move
you do the special move and then if you
want to enhance it tap the Peterburg
button which is the r2 button and use a
borrow meter it enhances it see normally
it doesn't start a comment they just get
knocked down but the beater burn one and
get popped up high or your lightning
kick just a single kick but the meter
burn competent Posse which I use in that
sitcom was nice you did right you were
so good sick and he has various changes
like his lightning kick is still a great
combo starter but now it is unsafe so he
no longer just opened you up without any
risk at all but safe unsafe meaning the
opponent gets a counter if they walk in
a counter meaning punish me hitting a
punish meaning you get to attack him
because you blocked his attack attack so
now that works it works okay
all right so what's some of this
returning movies in yes
his rhetoric moves are you know the
lightning tick
he has a quantum tunneling climatology a
quantum tunneling which is like in a
pair he will absorb boobs or actually go
invincible like if you throw an
interaction and he cannot be if you can
meet her permanence in decline all right
he has his running man stands his back
and he freed of an option
tornado my favorite slide run over you
he has a sonic pound which you can
actually control the distances in
coastal on far one you can Peter Burnett
and get comma and he has most of his big
old baggage back to lock range just for
two which is an overhead is down one
which is a low combo starter and his
character power is the speed force where
time slows and then the opponent is slow
flash actually moves normal speed normal
speed for him but he's actually so fast
that he's not almost being hair color if
that makes I I'm gonna let you go that I
lost you there buddy alright so I think
that kind of covers a lot of us basic
one yes his super room well I think we
should wait for the two Leon don't
should we wait for you let me do it now
do it now all right
are you ready yeah ready are you sure
you're ready yes what should we talk
about it for another second okay that's
good we actually the flash is in the
past when we talked about it and he's
been ready since before I even came in
and we're just not catching up to you
keep inviting it on these soon I know
okay
[Music]
[Music]
so he killed the dinosaurs
so flash went back in time and back in
time and - and they there's two
timelines going on yes in the same super
moon and they intersect at the end that
is correct
nailed it Annie destroyed the Sphinx's
nose yeah and Android designs amai the
dinosaurs both so that is the craziest
super ever it's a it's a it's a pretty
good one it contains two separate
timelines and you meet and you're
supposed to meet yourself in a jungle
yeah you ever want to do he's messing
with time think about it probably
completely out of whack now so the
stream just flip their lids yes yeah
it's going really fast yeah there's
other it turns out they like they like
the super moon well that's very
appropriate for the stream to be moving
fast right now boy ah so let's see what
else he has to him alright so let's go
to so you get it right the first time he
does this a lot
he's a professional though he's go to
our second loadout and look at that
first off that looks awesome
I'm pretty happy yeah that's I was good
I was talking to Ed today but yeah I got
some get real attack yes like I got some
really cool flash costume set up for how
much there's one of them where flash
looks like a sports car this is like
he's like a sports car it's amazing
alright so the first ability we have
equipped is the head dive which is a
dive kick but instead of a kick uses his
head
because he's got to mix it up so yeah
he's flashing sweat he dead this is a
quick overhead attack and when you have
his character power action that looks
like on the most fun thing that is
probably my most fun thing about run
that's awesome yeah
so that is head dive and we also have
forgive : did here did you never meet or
burn the fists
we're getting there we're getting there
this is a really cool one um so one of
the things about the flash is he's not
really a long-distance rider right right
great up close but he's not so great
from a distance right we're at his owner
what if you're having trouble against
dr. fade or dead shot or maybe you're
fighting bait and you want to keep him
out what what could you possibly do
throw something at him throw something
at him so now he has a projectile he
does this isn't another this isn't one
of the abilities that billions you had
for years or your custom loadout if
you're having a really hard time and
you've always thought I love the flash
but I wish I had a fireball there you go
so what's the difference between the
regular version and the mirror Reaper
the regular one doesn't do a whole lot
of damage and it just kind of stumbles
them back and here everyone's a little
bit slower but the trade-off is you get
a big chunk of damage and not awesome
really yeah definitely want to look at
the coolest mmm alright anything else we
want to go over we are gonna go over one
more load out all right I'm excited to
see what you picked for him to wear yeah
it's pretty cool
I'm happy with what I did this week oh I
really like in a blue that's pretty neat
alright so a lot of people have been
asking can you not a lot of people
coming up and with this custom loadout
you can now what this does for you is
flashes free up earlier so he is
actually able to continue combos if I
didn't drop it seems like you went to
the school of Lansdowne Tyler's own the
Tyler zone so he can actually pause , or
you can use it to restate do this and
then there's staggered right there and
you can go into your mix up so you can
either extend your combo and just push
the full screen or you can actually stop
your combo to fix them up even further
but only what this is doing so that's a
really good ability if you want extended
compost so just to be straight the
normal fist fury is just a standard
moody right have to unlock the ability
meter per crate and then you get a
replacement first tornado fist the speed
native which is big tornado move Peter
burns to get a chocolate combo and this
is a tremendous can tire if the opponent
is in the vicinity of this at all
they're going to pick down and it's very
very fast it's a great Punisher it's a
great move to just do admits agree I
think you're going to come in it's
basically a mover if you're in the space
you're going to pick them yeah so it's
another great great ability you're
getting sucked into the board you're
gonna suck them um
that's awesome yeah so those are the two
moves
they're on their own more they're lovely
we're gonna save but do you want to do
the super again uh sure okay
[Music]
awesome so every tool so cool we gonna
grab the controller yeah if we could get
some face view for us real quick face
view face view basically
so talk about now what like a returning
Flash Player like they'll still feel
like